the New York attorney general launched
an investigation into Donald Trump after
Michael Cohen his former attorney
testified before the U.S Congress saying
that Trump had manipulated values on
documents that he had submitted to
various places including financial
institutions
one of the properties where some of that
manipulation had happened was 40 Wall
Street so the Trump Organization for
years lied about 40 Wall Street in fact
they're still lying about 40 Wall Street
if you go on to the Trump organization's
website and look to see how tall 40 Wall
Street is they'll tell you that it's
more stories than it actually is if you
look to see how many square feet it is
they'll say that it's larger than it
actually is and certainly if you were to
ask the Trump organization how valuable
it was they would tell you that it's far
more valuable than it actually is this
is a really really valuable building we
estimate that it's worth about 211
million dollars but the Trump
organization at various points was
valuing it and with the help of others
it wasn't just them at over 500 million
dollars using sort of Twisted math that
allows you to get to those numbers so 40
Wall Street also known as the Trump
building is a 63-story skyscraper in
lower Manhattan it has about 1.1 million
square feet but Donald Trump got
involved with it in about 1995 and
updated it and has filled it up with a
bunch of sort of small uh you know
investment shops and legal firms and
that sort of thing 40 Wall Street When
Donald Trump got involved with it was
basically a disaster the building had
been empty for a long time or at least
largely empty a couple of other
developers had come along and seen this
enormous building and saw a lot of
potential but weren't ultimately able to
make much out of it Donald Trump to his
credit bought it for almost nothing he
says 1.3 million dollars it's right
around that figure and now we think it's
worth 211 million dollars so this was a
heck of an investment now it didn't just
happen with the snap of his fingers he
had to invest over 100 million dollars
into rehabbing the building but look
it's been a great deal for him uh the
trick is is that recently the building's
finances have started to take a little
bit of a downward turn he doesn't look
like he's gonna get this enormous
windfall that it appeared that he would
get at one point so Donald Trump lied to
Forbes and other media organizations at
the same time that he was allegedly
lying to all of these Banks and if you
talk to people inside the Trump
organization including Michael Cohen
whose testimony sparked this entire
investigation they'll tell you that this
is all part of one concerted effort uh
that basically if he lied to Forbes and
he could use Forbes valuations to help
support the numbers that he was saying
at Banks and if he convinced Banks and
lenders then he could use those
valuations to help prop up his members
on the Forbes list so it was all part of
one concerted effort so any way that he
could he was using bits of information
to try to push the values higher
certainly in his conversations with
Forbes and according to the attorney
general also in his Communications with
lending institutions
the attorney general has now filed a
lawsuit uh as part of that lawsuit she's
hoping to inflict all sorts of pain on
Trump and the Trump organization the big
dollar number is that they're hoping to
discourage 250 million dollars from the
Trump organization now remember the
Trump organization is just Donald Trump
so that would be money coming out of his
own pocket that would be damaging to him
he could afford it right now we estimate
that he has 375 million dollars in cash
but it would certainly limit the sorts
of things that he could do with his
business it would mean that he would
have to be much more careful with new
opportunities that he could pursue he
couldn't for instance you know dump 200
million dollars and insurance social the
new social media app that he's
developing and then still have 250
million dollars to hand over to
authorities so it would constrain him in
certain ways and it also would just be a
massive blow against his ego as just the
filing of the lawsuit has been you know
know now he has officials saying in
court documents that he's lied about his
net worth for years that's an
embarrassing thing for Donald Trump and
as it continues to evolve and you know
they respond to the lawsuit and the
process sort of works its way ah there's
going to be more talk of all of this
more evidence displayed and that will
continue to be embarrassing for Trump in
addition to being financially harmful
[Music]